hi everyone my name is Ilya I'm one of
the co-founders at segment and I'm here
to talk to you about how to set up
analytics and the analytics foundation
to build your MVP and to measure these
primary and secondary metrics so this is
going to be a little bit more of a
tactical guide around what tools are
there and then oolitic space in the
marketing space which one should we
actually be using how do I set them up
cool just before I get started a lot of
you may not know what segment is it's an
analytics API where you can send
analytics data and then toggle on
different tools so we send the cool
market position where we can actually
see what tools startups are using and we
can bring that information to you
secondly we've been around for about six
years and so we have information about a
lot of different startups as they grew
and what tools they used so we're gonna
be sharing a lot of those today cool so
why talk about why even focus on the
analytics obviously primary and
secondary metrics drive the MVP and
product market fit process and you're
using that to actually test product
market fit you're also using it once you
get out of product market fit strict
search to actually focus the team so
maybe there's gonna be an acquisition
issue in the company that's preventing
your growth or maybe the users that
you're getting aren't as engaged or
maybe you're having some monetization
issues and so the funnel actually is a
forcing function to understand your
business and where founders should be
actually spending their time and then
finally all the way from you know to
three-person team to Google with 1
million employees you're actually using
metrics to operate and drive teams so
eventually you have an engineering team
you have a marketing team and so what
gold do you set in front of the
marketing team use analytics for that ok
so today we're gonna cover a few
different things so first you always
start with the funnel when you're
thinking about analytics so that's the
sequential series of steps so your users
go through to actually get value and
then pay you as well then we're gonna
talk about collecting data for your
analytics tools then we're going to talk
about the top three metrics so this will
include primary and secondary metrics
that work for most products and then a
product market fit methodology that you
can apply on top of that and then
finally we'll make recommendations about
what tools are the best in the market
right now that help the product market
fit journey ok so to start where we
started the funnel so we'll make an
example funnel for Netflix which is a
company
super familiar with any b2b product or
b2c product actually has this type of
funnel where you acquire a user you
engage a user over a period of time that
loop is called retention and then
finally you monetize the user and then
metrics both primary and secondary are
performance indicators on top of each
stage in the funnel so I on top of
acquisition you can ask yourself how
many new users did I get this week
versus last week and what's my growth
rate there for engagement you take a
cohort of users so from you know Sunday
to the following Monday you you have you
know 16 people sign up and then you can
track that cohort of users week over
week and see what percentage of them are
still using the product four weeks later
which is a good example of how to track
retention and then we talked about
monetization which is how much that new
revenue did I make this week versus last
week okay and then you apply your own
custom business funnel to this so if
your Netflix we're all familiar the
users sign up for Netflix then they play
videos in a loop the Netflix is
obviously very sticky watching it a lot
and then finally when the trial runs out
you do subscription upgraded and you get
access to more content okay so how do
you collect data once you have this
funnel
so there's analytics API is out there
I'm using segments as an example you
basically want to say user user 1 2 3 in
this case has done user signup event and
they happen to be an organic user which
means they're not invited by someone
else then if your Netflix you might say
the users video played and eventually
subscription upgraded and so this is how
you instrument your tracking and your
mobile app or your or your web app then
you think about event properties so
imagine your Netflix and you're holding
one of these video played events in your
hands and you're wondering questions
about it so you know what video art is
the user actually playing how long is
the video how far did the person get
inside of the video right equivalent if
you're holding a subscription upgraded
event you're going to want to derive
monetization as a Northstar metric so if
you're a subscription business you want
to send your monthly recurring revenue
if you're a transactional business like
e-commerce or retail you want to send
the actual value of the transaction okay
so then you push this out into your web
app your mobile app then you start
seeing the data come in you look at the
debugger you see okay user signup is
here every
good you add your first analytics tool
will use amplitude as a good example
here amplitude and Mixpanel are pretty
awesome analytics tools out in the
market right now and then you start
seeing data flow inside of one of these
analytics tools so this is amplitude you
can start seeing user signups growing as
soon as you launched the real like
mobile or web app okay so now that you
have analytics set up it's time to focus
on three different metrics the first one
is the acquisition metrics signups per
week it's really nice if you're a b2b
business to cut this by the invite type
so I you have organic users which are
just signing up from coming to your
website direct sign up and then some
users are inviting other users so those
are invite type right so when you're
thinking about growth it's really
important to think about the organic
user in that case right another example
why if I'm properties are important the
way you create this is you go to
amplitude you say event segmentation
report user sign up next here's your
graph right so it's as easy as that just
website some data gets to amplitude and
then you can see the amount of organic
users every week and then if you're
working on the acquisition step as a
secondary metric you can basically say
today 218 users organically signed up in
the last week but by the end of the
month we want that to be at 300 and
we're gonna execute projects a B and C
this month and then we're gonna watch
this graph every single day on a TV
dashboard in our office or apartment
wherever we work and then we're gonna
see if our efforts are actually driving
this right so that's an idea of data
driven operation of a team you set a
metric and a goal and then you drive
towards that every day okay the second
one is retention to cohorts so someone
recently asked about retention what
we'll talk about that right now
so with retention you want to think
about cohorts of users so you want to
say Monday to Sunday let's say December
10th through the 7th December 17th 16
users signed up and then you look at
those 16 users as they use your product
on a week 0 which is their signup week
week 1 a week 2 week 3 and week 4 and
the general idea here is like you can
convince your mom or your grandma to use
your product once but even your mom or
your grandma won't continue to come back
and use your product over time every
single week right and so if you see
users that are addicted that are coming
back week over week that's a really good
sign of product market
fit so this business can see that the
December tenth cohort only 6.25% of
those users are still around on a week
four and that's a pretty low amount
right so you probably want that to be
somewhere between 20 or 30 at least and
so you can set a goal saying I'm going
to talk to a bunch of these target users
and try to figure out you know why
they're not getting value out of the
product and then make some changes as
well okay so what metric do you actually
pick this is taken from one of gustaf
slides pretty awesome you think about
what value your company is giving to
your users so Airbnb gives you value by
letting you stay at different rental
properties around the world right and
they want you to do that at least one
time a year otherwise they consider you
a churned user equivalently Facebook
gives you value by letting you look at
the newsfeed and you know connect with
your friends and they want you to do
that at least daily or monthly once and
so when you think about product market
fit
you basically have these two different
curves that happen so we have that
cohort of 16 users that signed up in one
a week and we track them over time and
so what ends up happening is for
products that don't have product market
fit they end up tending to go to zero
because people just don't care about the
product right and that's definition
product market fit for those tools and
the products that do have product market
fit you'll see some kind of natural
plateau don't mind this axis it should
be somewhere you know between 20 and 30
percent at least okay so how do you
create this graph it seems kind of
complicated right luckily both Mixpanel
amplitude have really awesome reports
for this so in amplitude it's a
retention analysis report you say users
enter the cohort with user signup and
then they return with the video player
to the subscription upgraded event
that's the value event and then you
press next and out comes this graph and
then you could look at for week
retention for cohorts improve the
product and watch as new cohorts that
strike the four week mark do better or
worse right and that shows you whether
your changes week over week are actually
improving okay finally a revenue so this
is the primary metric they want to be
thinking about you'll use for a
subscription business the subscription
upgraded event you'll do a property sum
over new plan monthly recurring revenue
you press next and outcomes your weekly
that your revenue graph and then you
could set monthly goals on top of this
to make sure you're growing
the at the rates that you want to be
okay
finally I if you have a founding team
it's really good to basically put all
the stuff on a dashboard and then put
this dashboard on a TV in your office
it's incredibly incredibly important
basically this is kind of the the
difference between being a data-driven
team and not a data-driven team a lot of
founders actually set up their analytics
but then don't look at them ever again
because it can be painful right while a
data-driven team will put it on a TV and
talk about projects talk about what
those projects are actually changing the
metrics that they're trying to drive and
then just completely understand the
business every single day right and this
kind of company in this kind of founder
will actually scale to build better high
performance companies because the next
team of employees they hire will also be
looking at that same TV dashboard and be
driven off those same metrics so really
important get a TV next what you want to
do is have some kind of social
accountability around your metrics so if
you have your friends your parents your
advisors your investors package up how
your business is doing into an email
this helps you synthesize what is
actually happening and then send it out
to to those advisers and tell them where
the business is struggling and what your
plan is to fix it this allows the
advisors to quickly understand the
business and then respond back with much
more appropriate advice cool and now
we'll go into the startup stack so these
are tools that we recommend that help
this kind of tactical process of setting
up these metrics so I'm gonna talk a
little bit about that MVP business
business workflow that that Michael
talked about earlier so initially you're
building an MVP segment built about
seven different MVPs before we actually
found segments and all of those failed
and eventually we found we found one
that worked and the process of actually
building that BP is incredibly important
so once you have that little experiment
built you want to enter private beta
which basically just means getting like
10 20 30 customers to actually try this
product and then having very direct
lines of communication open with them
what segment does nowadays every new
product we ship we open slack channels
with each one of our customers and we
have the product managers sit in those
slack channels and talk with the
customers for the products that don't
get product market fit the customers
just stop responding and we're asking
asking asking they're not responding
right and for the products that do have
product market fit the customers are
immediately being like oh
we don't why don't you have this feature
this is broken might I tread inviting my
team and this is network not working so
instead of you kind of pulling at the
customer the customer starts pulling at
you that's that's a good feeling of
product market fit okay so at some point
the private beta is going well you feel
like people really care about this you
understand your target customer then you
want to get a larger market segment to
use it
that's the launch that we talked about
earlier try to get there as quickly as
possible and then a launch is just more
users that you get to test product
market fit on and so if you feel product
market fit there then you can start
scaling the company right and you hire
salespeople and you start doing paid
paid marketing and things like that so
different tools will guide you
throughout this throughout this process
so as you're building an MVP and you're
about to give it to the first group of
customers install Google Analytics
install amplitude Google Analytics will
tell you who's coming from the Internet
to your website and an amplitude will
tell you which features are they using
how engaged are they with that feature
set unless you're able to stand over the
shoulders of all of your users 100% of
the time analytics is the next best
alternative for that we also install
live chat on the page
so either slack with your customers or
if you can't do that then maybe have a
live chat available in the beginning of
segment customers would ping us you know
day and night and that's where we got
the most valuable feedback from them so
just as many open channels of
communication as possible next data
warehouse this is something that we
recommend it used to be expensive is no
longer expensive today basically if you
have a non technical co-founder on your
team but want to ask questions around
the data and they'll always ask the
technical co-founder we'll have to
provide the answers so data warehouse
kind of democratizes the data not only
for the non-technical co-founders but
for everyone else
in the company that you hire after
company dashboards obviously I we should
probably move that to the left email and
push tools so as soon as you as soon as
user sign up you want to send them an
email I'll talk about that in a second
and then and then a help desk so at some
point you'll have so much support
tickets if you start feeling product
market fit and if they're all going to
your Gmail one founder will just get
overwhelmed and not be able to answer
them so you want to have a shared inbox
where multiple founders can I can
respond okay now I'm gonna go through a
few different recipes of these different
tools there
we found really helpful in product
market fit so the first one is improving
product usability almost every product
that's launched is unusable or highly
unusable for the first three months
while you have the kinks and we see this
with every single product no matter how
much effort we put into it ahead of time
as soon as customers hit it they start
using it in ways that you just don't
expect and so there's this tool called
full story which helps you look at
sessions of customers as they use your
website so I'll tell a quick story on
this this is a new feature in personas
which is one of segments products and we
launched them the metrics looked
horrible so like customers are coming in
but they weren't actually completing it
they weren't they weren't using the
product and we thought oh god you know
this likely doesn't have product market
fair we have to go back to the drawing
board
then one of the designers and her team
had this amazing idea let's look at the
full story and so we see this user going
in about to start this creation workflow
they find this button they clearly don't
understand what the button does they get
so frustrated they just exit the page
and so we saw this with a multiple with
multiple different customers coming in
and so we're like okay we just have to
fix that button we fixed that button
immediately all the metrics got better
right and so that's why it's important
to have this type of viewing either to
stand over your customers shoulders
which is great what the stripe
co-founders did or get a full story
which is more scalable way to do that
okay I call this the 43 minute founder
email so when we launch a segment we
would wait about 43 minutes and we would
email the code or email the customer and
say hey I'm Ilya thanks so much for
signing up for segment your next step
here is to add a source to segment and
if you have any questions at all please
email me or call me anytime I'm
available for you since we launched that
email in 2013 we've had hundreds of
thousands of responses to it so it's
it's the connection between you and the
customer over email that if they get
confused they'll respond to it what you
can use is a tool called customer IO
it's a behavioral email tool which will
say every time a user signs up wait you
know 30 minutes 40 minutes 50 minutes
whatever and then automatically send
them this content and you could template
the first name the company name and so
forth based off of your analytics data
so huge recipe recommend and then
finally for democratizing data access I
say this is more advanced so this is
after you're in your MVP stage you're
feeling good about product market fit
you might want to install data warehouse
like Google bigquery and then mode
analytics is a bi tool that works on top
of it this lets you ask questions on top
of the raw data that you might not be
able to do an amplitude and mix panel
just any kind of question you can ask
for sequel and then even the
non-technical co-founders will
eventually pick up sequel and then start
asking these questions themselves okay
one common failure mode that we see with
customers is trying to pick the perfect
tool mix panel or amplitude you know
bigquery or redshift and spending way
way way too long thinking about that the
truth of the matter is you shouldn't
optimize for picking the right tool
right now both amplitude and mix panel
will give you exactly the same result at
your stage instead just get through that
decision as quickly as possible but set
yourself up for change in the future so
this is an example diagram that shows a
customer of segments that use different
tools over a period of about three years
and so you can see that they used about
eight different tools between 2015 and
2017 and they either hired someone or
they decided that their tools are no
longer doing the job and they switch
from one set of tools to another so
best-in-class tools change every two
years just be prepared for a change and
don't spend too much time trying to
perfect your choice right now okay this
is my recommendation of what tools are
the best for the MVP process I'll walk
you through them right now so Google
Analytics is for understanding what
users are coming to your website
amplitude is for feature analytics
Google bigquery is to democratize data
access with a data warehouse which is
just a database of data mode is the the
tool use on top of that to ask questions
on top of bigquery intercom is like a
list of all of your customers they're
really good CRM for early-stage folks
full story is for improving product
usability in customer iOS for emailing
your customers once you get big enough
you can start using Google Ads Facebook
Ads to actually do the data acquisition
okay so I'll just jump straight to the
slide when we were really young we when
we were in 2011-2012 we didn't have a
lot of money and so we didn't want to
use all these different tools and so we
used Google spreadsheet for a CRM we
didn't use asana or Trello because they
were too expensive so we used emails and
the only things we paid for we're
basically github and AWS to host our
products right so today happy to say the
segment is now free for early-stage
startups so for all you folks there's a
bitly link down here that will send that
afterwards and it's in the deals and
then also segments went out and we did a
bunch of deals with these customers so
that if you're early-stage you can now
get all of these tools for free so enjoy
that and start using them to basically
accelerate your product market fit
process thank you
[Music]
you're asking about growth rate so
you're asking it if you're starting with
a very small base of users what growth
rate you need to be on to make to make
growth meaningful yeah it completely
depends on the product right so if
you're an enterprise b2b company then
your closing deals for you know 10 15 20
thousand dollars then only a few of
those customers can make I can give you
enough capital to hire more people to do
more marketing entire larger sales team
if you are selling you know shirts and
pants then you probably need a higher
volume so totally depends on it so it
depends the kind of company you're
building
yep so the question is what kind of what
kind of retention period do you want to
look at if I if you're renting
properties like an Airbnb yeah that's a
really good question
it really those kind of periods depend
on the kind of company you're building
so I'm giving one presentation but
there's hundreds of different companies
that that need to apply the information
slightly differently so if your Airbnb
you probably would expect people to at
least come back to your app you know
like how often do people travel right
they travel you know once a month once a
quarter right and so that's the that's
the period that you want to make sure
that they come back at yeah so it's not
like week is correct for everyone but
it's correct for the majority of
companies exactly keep a pulse yep
awesome all right well thank you so much
[Applause]
you